Oh, I slayed it this weekend.
Oh, deets please!
Blonde, 5'10", biceps for days.
Yum yum yum!
[Unison] Oh!
Fresh meat.
Hey Big Red.  You look a little lost.
You need someone to hold your hand?
Hope the carpets match the drapes.  You red everywhere?
Uhm, I'm detective Houston.
Oh.  Houston!
We have a boner!
[Laughter]
You have a boner?
[Unison] Yeah.
You all have boners?
Oh yes, we all have boners.
And I bet you have those big nipples.
Those nasty pink puffy ones.
Okay, that's enough.
I'm just trying to get my desk organized for my job.
Okay, take it easy.  We're just paying you a compliment.
You know, if you'd like, I can help you organize
your hands on my tits.
[Unison] Oh!
[Dog noises]
Oh no!
Oh, me so sorry.
Oh, I knocked it over.
Oh, it's on the floor
Baby gotta pick it up.  Pick it up.
Ah!
Hot!  Hot!  Hot!
I'm a professional!  Okay?
Treat me like a professional man please.
Calm down, Candy Dick.
If you didn't want us to holler at you,
you shouldn't have worn those pants.
I dress for me.
And if you didn't want us to look,
you should have tied a sweater around that apple booty baby.
Apple booty baby!
Do you understand how difficult it is
to be the only man on the force?
I've been dealing with grabby handed perverts like you
since the academy.
But now it's my time.
I climbed that ladder and I am Detective
and I demand some respect!
For my mind, for my abilities.
Not may apple booty.
Or my big ass dick.
[Sniffs]
We're gross.
You have feelings.
I thought he was liking what we were doing.
He wasn't.  That's the problem.
Oh my God.
If men don't like this, then how do we tell them
that we like them?
I don't know!
We're just monsters!  We don't know!
I'm sorry that I made you cry, guys.
[Sobbing]
It's really hard to be the only guy on the force.
How hard is it, baby?
Ah!
[Unison] Ohhh!
Dick dick dick dick!
You get a dick!  You get a dick!
Hey dude!  Here's a shot of dick!
Oh, I just came.
Let's cut!
[Laughter]